Morgan Spurlock's outside we should
bring him in he's got a new documentary
that's premiering this Saturday at 9
p.m. on discovery called rats I watched
it I haven't I didn't know it I have to
pay attention it is disgusting I would
claim my farts
welcome Morgan Spurlock I just gotta
just for those of you at home who are
listening it smells spectacular it's got
a nice mmm you've done a lot of you've
dealt with a lot of disgusting things in
your every morning I do starting this
morning yeah I'm sure super-sized me
contain quite a few McDonald's farts
there was it was a very smelly I smell I
smelled you see with that film also it's
like you had no idea I smoked so bad by
the end of that film like I just like I
was just putting off like this terrible
Mik Musk like just this deep-fried funk
and you really talk about the stench
that goes along it's like a real proper
terrible smell my girlfriend hated me at
the time you probably you probably could
have got a lot more people to agree with
you on the McDonald's thing if you're
like also it makes you stink also in
smellivision sweat like your armpit odor
or like it's like bad [ __ ] was like what
would you know just the fart smelled bad
and then like kind of what was sweating
out of me anytime I would sweat just
smelled terrible I love a good
McDonald's fart so sometimes when Kenny
and I'd be on the road I'd get like at
2:00 in the morning there's just nothing
and you're like I'm nauseous I gotta eat
yeah I throw a cheeseburger down the
next exit as the krinkle of the [ __ ]
paper open it was like it smells very
similar on both ends that's the thing so
I can show this documentary I didn't
know what we were able to see it I'm
really bad at this
seems no technological guys he doesn't
tend to check emails but these gotta
text me and tell me I got a thing for
you I get so many emails I should I
should have seen so what is this about
about rats cuz we were all fascinated
with these awful creatures yeah so well
a friend of mine a guy named Josh Braun
optioned a book by Robert Sullivan came
out a few years ago New York Times
bestseller about rats which was all
about like rat infestations in New York
the history of rats and so my friend
brought me this book and he goes with
the tell me what you think about it and
I read it and I'm a I'm a lifelong
horror family
I grew up at crazy horror fan you made
it like a horror whole idea and so so I
grew up loving like I had terrible
parents back in the 70s where my they
would take me to movies you should never
take kids to like you know The Exorcist
or The Omen or you know jaws and
scanners and scanners was the movie that
made me want to make movies like when
Michael Ironside made that guy's head
explode that was it change my life you
see I'm gonna suck your brain drive yeah
exactly they say you see the green
inferno oh yeah yeah I love them yeah go
back to like everything that's not made
anymore I think very 70s like just
aníbal movies it was like they have I
just I was having a whole was having a
whole cannibal cannibal conversation
yesterday but it's so after I wrote
after I read the book I went back to my
friend Josh and I said well what if we
made a horror documentary so it'll be a
straight doc it'll be all true but we
shoot it like a horror film score it
like a horror film you know make it feel
as dark and it's creepy it's great and
so the film came out really dark and
fucked-up and I think it's it's so
awesome like I'm really proud of it and
it's not like it's a very different from
people who are used to Morgan Spurlock
documentary that's not like you're not a
character in it at all I'm not in one
frame of the whole movie because I
thought it was scary enough without it
without putting the space but the space
in the movie it's gonna be better and
you know we have an amazing editor
Pierre to call who also scored the film
so it sounds like this great like 1980
John Carpenter film like it is it's got
it's got this great strip synth driven
soundtrack it's I didn't documentary
when I turned it on like III when I
first started watching like that opening
scene and the thing jumps and everything
yeah I was like what is this just a
movie about is this like that movie been
like what is what is Morgan doing now
and then about rats like I want to know
what what do you like well we know about
image but they're hard to kill and they
[ __ ] get it anywhere not me I watched
the movie I know a lot about I want to
know what would I learn if I check my
email so if you check your email and
watch the film which is this Saturday
night on discovery at 9 o'clock if you
if you watch the movie you'll learn so
many things we travel all around the
world this thing this isn't just like an
innate you know us problem or New York
problem although New York does have a a
tremendous amount of rats
Chicago is actually now number one in
America really congratulations Chicago
very proud of you guys but as you travel
around the world you start to see that
everywhere you go there are rat
infestations in the
Vietnam Cambodia we're in England we're
in France where's the worst I mean
America is bad but I think the worst
that we saw over the course of making
this film I mean India you get into like
Mumbai where there's also a lot of
people sleeping on the street so there's
a lot of people have to deal with kind
of being bitten in the middle of the
night and it's I think that where we saw
the worst was probably there that was my
that's probably my favorite part because
like we just gone in New York as the
movie goes like location to location to
location and just kind of shows how the
culture deals with this rat culture
mm-hm and we've just been in New York
and you see all this technology and the
cameras going down the drains and and
and and these Health Department things
and their methods and all this stuff and
then you go to India and they've got a
problem that's so bad thousands of
people are dying from the diseases that
the rats are carrying and they and they
have a they have a city group of
employees called the night rat killers
that go out at night that that go out
armed basically with like a net and a
stick and a flashlight
that's all in a bag and they go out and
they just Li and they kill rats with
their bare hands and it's one of the
most incredible things you'll ever see I
might have missed the point of the movie
though cuz I found myself I kept feeling
bad for the rats that people want to
kill I think that there are I think that
you know some people will probably feel
bad for them I think at the end of the
day a lot of people realize that they
are a menace
yeah a lot of ways and carry a lot of
disease and cause problems I mean the
things you some of the things you
learned or an I learned of course making
this film is just the way that rats
evolved like they evolved ten times
faster than human beings so that if you
if you create a poison to kill a rat
within a few generations they'll already
start to develop an immunity to that
poison right so I mean it is it is a
remarkable thing how how evolution has
just created this little survival
machine yes rats it was not seeing them
like that they had very quickly evolved
to the point where the poison did not
affect them whatsoever yeah
and they had like their whole little
communicated communities and and they
could communicate with each other where
like if you put poison out then they
showed it like they had a hidden camera
in so you could see it in the in the
ceiling of someplace that's right like
if you put poison out for a rat and they
don't know what the poison is they'll
send they'll leave it there and then
they'll send the weakest rat out too
to check it out and then they'll watch
and if that weak rat dies then they'll
leave it alone yeah they'll be all over
ya they pee all over them so they know
don't don't go near that rat or that
poison and so yeah so they have like
they have like you know fast I was been
ostracized by humanity if that's how we
did it here just covered in urine in my
own house I thought that was just called
Saturday yeah thank God I shower
communication - wow that's pretty wide I
cut the tails off yeah so they cut the
tails off of those to do the research
this this shot we're looking at the
trailer right now in studio and so this
is one of my favorite things in the
rural countryside of England they have
packs of terriers rat terriers and Jack
Russell Terriers that will go out and
hunt rats on farms so they have this big
day of it where they go out and they
have those hunting days they'll all that
people put on like their hunting gear
like they were going fox hunting and
they take these little these little
Terriers out and just they they dig up
where there were rats and they just like
kill hundreds and hundreds of rats and
that's needed they cause a havoc on the
farm that's exactly right so places
where they will grow they'll grow like
hunting birds or things like that cuz
rats will eat other birds rats will eat
other rats rats or rats are hungry
they're hungry and and super carnivores
so they will eat whatever is around and
and so on these farms where they they
have these types of livestock like they
will bring in these dogs to help control
the rat problem it's an amazing thing to
witness I'm so glad I don't live in the
city like I don't even know if you're
gonna want to watch it because they
really are every everywhere that scene
where like because they have a camera
that can go down drains that's right
so yeah suck a camera under the street
and and you see like they're like weird
you see if we can find one and you end
up seeing how many there are
where's the camera done we put there was
a crack in the sidewalk and so we
basically took the crack and we stuck it
under the crack in the sidewalk cuz you
see certain cracks a lot of those cracks
are caused by rat pads that are
underneath the sidewalk when you see a
perfect crack that goes from like a goes
from like either a drain to a building
that a lot of times that's caused by
rats underneath it and so we study yeah
so we stuck it into this crack as we can
see underneath and inside there there
was like dozens of rats just like
waiting to come out to get the food and
that's the problem in New York City in
big cities everywhere we are giving them
their sustenance every night we put out
the garbage and so every night the rats
like well why would we ever leave you
should put signs up yeah like to not eat
the food and not exactly no food here
just garbage
sorry just garbage to know there's all
these there's all these people were
trying to create they have like these
mint-flavored garbage bags that
apparently they say rats won't chew
through them because they hate the
flavor the garbage bag and the
exterminator we talk he's like oh yeah
those don't work don't you right through
those yeah yeah they can they're immune
to poison but mint is too much I hated
my where did you where on earth did you
find the New York exterminator for this
movie because he might be like tacky
doctor no he made my favorite character
he's one of the greatest characters that
I ever found in my life so once we knew
we're making the film I wanted to find
Quint I wanted to find yes I wanted to
find Quint on the boat you know who's
there saying 200 men went into the water
you know you wanted that guy who's going
to tell you those stories and so we
started just asking around New York City
saying where can we find Quint where is
the guy I want this salty old
exterminator and everybody no matter
where you went in the city or he's like
oh you got to call ed Sheehan you got a
call that she and out in Bay Ridge and
so so we go to Bay Ridge we meet with
that she and Eddie Ann's been doing this
forty nine years he's been killing rats
in New York City and so we just sit down
we talk to him we asked him some
questions he told us some stories
another like this is the guy this is
this is our this is a Robert Shaw for us
Wow it's just sitting there it's all
well lit and he's smoking his cigar and
just like letting you know like you did
you know rats you don't know right yeah
I know right yeah that's him that's
Eddie and so in he's clean shaven there
that was at the Film Festival Toronto
Film Festival premiere where the movies
part of The Midnight Madness section so
we kind of got that we got the blessing
of being a real proper horror film by
premiering a Midnight Madness we were
opposite Blair Witch and a bunch of
other great twist on movies who's
awesome so is that what made this
appealing for you very different opinion
right there that is not the is that what
made this appealing that it felt like
you were making like a horror movie yes
well that's I I didn't want to make just
a straight historic movie like rats came
from Mongolia and the 15th century I
said that was not
movies I like making I like making even
documentaries like making movies to feel
like movies and and the ability to kind
of try something different make a real
genre-bending film which I think the
film does a great job of and so it is a
straight doc you will learn so much when
you watch this but it plays like a
horror film it feels like yeah it's
amazing if they are the most fast rats
roaches you can get people to watch it
on them all day long it's just
disgusting it's great in the fact that
Discovery Channel which we were so
excited about so we pitched them first
we said well here's what we want to make
thank you for sure they're gonna be like
nope not for us they were like oh yeah
let's make this they were on board they
completely supported us the whole time
they're like whatever you guys want to
do they just they kind of gave us gave
us free rein tiny gray creepiest
weirdest movie we could reel and it
really creeps ya like I was sitting
there I was watching part of it on a
train yeah New York yeah and I just felt
like there was just a right every every
30 seconds I had to look down since
there's a rat that was controlling my
paint color stuff cuz you've seen the
YouTube videos right where the guy falls
asleep
well that's an all table way that's no
well that that story that rat that ran
up the guy's body's asleep on the subway
and Pizza rat both created by a New York
performance artists both fakes both fake
videos I didn't know that this
performance artists shot the videos and
then put them out of the press and then
suddenly I picked up everywhere
everybody thought they were real Oh rat
crawling up the guy is not real also
fake I've had a rock fell at me but it
was some of my friends pet my friend had
a pet rat and she put it and it crawled
up and the weird post feeling their
little claws dig get two of them and
they were fat and they get these little
red mites on them I don't know what
those are but even domesticated rats get
them but they were her pets and they
still felt a little looser Ebola feeling
them on how they create this that guy's
is that guy the performance artists know
that no no that's not the process of
girl names are do Lou and the guy is
someone guys someone that she that she
drained and that's that was I'm trained
and she's a rat she also created she's
not the same one with the crickets is
she I don't think so I don't think so
like there's uh like there's but she
will only just like we said do we want
to talk about this and so we we reached
out to her and she sent us a video of
her cuz she wears this mask when she
talks to you and then disguises her
voice like it should have ordered or
gruul
we will talk Google both work it sounds
like we're not putting this new here
this is not going exactly that's not a
mob witness yeah exactly
that's pretty yeah there that's what
u're that costume that's it she where
are the videos I never get freaked out
by that like a meaning I don't know no
but if I'm walking and I see them
scurrying past your feet from garbage to
the to the the bushes it you know I
don't necessarily love it but I'm like
they're not gonna jump on me they want
they want garbage yeah they'll only jump
on you in cornered like if they feel
like they have no other way to get out
then they'll they will jump and they'll
jump right for your chest so they'll try
and jump like right and they can jump
like four to five they getting between
four and six feet in the air depending
on how big the rat is and so they'll go
for your chest cuz they want to get as
close to your face as possible because
they'll know that that will usually
scare you away just so they can have the
ability to jump and then run but then I
want to bite you they want to get out of
it they want to get out of it so rats
how about the old the 12th century thing
they would do will they put that on your
chest like a bucket they heat the other
side of it that's right yeah so they
would basically get like a metal bucket
they put a rat on your chest and put a
metal bucket on the top and start to
burn it and then a rat will eat through
your stomach and eat through your away
from the basket to escape the heat oh my
god yeah that was like a medieval
medieval rabbit oh yeah they did that an
American Psycho in the book oh they did
yeah that's tunnel into a girl's [ __ ]
and then he [ __ ] out cuz their [ __ ]
the book is so good because their vagina
they won't fit the other tube so he
burns it with acid that he puts the tube
in and then he puts the rat in and it
burrows into her stomach and then he
pulls the tube out oh what do you I
didn't put that in the movie canned
laughter you forget to leave things for
the sequel so you flew you were there
for all the chutes are just some oh I
was there for the whole movie
so was that creepy to be around that
amount of rats and temple the rat
temples by far so the film ends like
that we go to this place in India or you
are awesome thank you will you go to
this place in India where they believe
and this is because in this the India is
a gigantic country I'm a huge billions
people live there and so you go from
Mumbai where they go out at night with
the night rat killers and kill them with
sticks and nets and then just to the
north of that in Rajasthan there is a
there is a temple
where there are 35,000 rats in this one
building all alive and the people who
live in the town and come to worship
there believe that these are their
ancestors that when they die as humidity
it's there that you are reincarnated as
a rat right and then the rat lives his
life and then when he dies he's
reincarnated back as a person true no
it's just dreck and so they so people go
there and they basically feed them they
hang out with them they play with them
they feed on my hatred they feed them by
hand they there's these giant bowls that
the rats are in is the worst that rats
drink milk out of and they come up and
they drink the milk out of it with the
with the rats
there's a Z there's a picture right
there that is unbelievable there's
literally a scene where all the rats are
drinking milk out of this bowl milk and
the guy is talking to the camera and
it's Lea and you can see you see there's
like turds floating in it and yet you're
in floating on the top of the milk and
it's just sum up he's scooping up with
his hand and be like the milk is good
the milk is good milk is fine yuck do
the do the rats bite these people or no
I mean they they've sure they've been
people who have been we talked to them
they said yeah people have gotten bitten
but you know it's usually just a play
bite they're not like trying to fight
you or hurt you you know do the rats
associate people with bringing them food
oh I said this temple completely like
that's these rats these these rats are
not afraid of one human in that place
because the humans take care of them did
you feel when you would get back to your
hotel rooms or whatever like in rats
everywhere I would come home I would
come home and I would shy there was not
enough soap in every hotel I was saying
so I would go in I'd have the hottest
shower I'd be in the shower for like 35
40 minutes just like scrubbing myself
but it is a it is an amazing amazing I
would go and look there like that
especially since they're so used to
people oh yeah but the whole wait are
you gonna work why do you know where
slippers but you know because you have
to you have to take your shoes off yeah
you got a worship it's the temple you
know right Debbie respect for you yes
yep so you have to walk around barefoot
you know you're having a [ __ ] foot
worship fetish in that shitty country
that's crawling oh man
oh there's our dulu right there awesome
I said that to women I've dated but rats
in my shoes leaving their little rat
shits yeah I guess you knew going into
this that this would be all about the
footage
right yeah so you had to get that rap
footage we were shooting in the sewers
of Paris which they wouldn't let us
shoot in the sewers of New York City
which is the they are they are like no
no it's a safety hazard I'm like is it
is it the safety hazard is something
else another reason why you don't want
us in there and so what we're sucked we
had some good socks it's a little bit of
coverage it's not gonna be you know kids
just sit this is [ __ ] horrible but so
you're shooting in the sewers in Paris
but we're shooting in sewers in Paris
full on like Tyvek suits like the
wellington boots him to come way up but
with the duct tape around just because
like you said some point so you're going
through the source repair so you're like
you're wading through anywhere between 6
to 12 inches of like full-on excrement
that's being flushed out of the
buildings and just rats running around
everywhere down there I mean it was one
of the most disgusting places I've ever
shot in my life and then none of it
ended up in the film and so you're in
there it's like oh my god I would can't
leave I spent a whole day and like a
Paris sewer and none of it made it in
the movie you know what the most the
most helpful part of the whole movie is
its that you see what a rat piss stain
it's like so you know so you can go to a
restaurant and you can see cuz you see
that now you look down at the sidewalk
you see them everywhere that piss stain
look like it is uh it is usually like it
so you can see the gob so it looks like
a circular piece but it has a pulled
into it because they usually dribble at
the end oh god bless then slice it so
it's like a circular piece of like a
little dribble so it looks like an
extended balloon almost that's one in
the ceiling so when you have ceiling
tiles that look like that there's
usually an infestation in your roof
where they're peeing in the ceiling
tiles and it will spread and dance like
that in the ceiling yeah it looks like a
water style but that's usually rat urine
Oh see that on the ceilings a lot yeah
and that's usually like comes from I'm
looking at the ceiling in here now
what's happening this is the studio here
looks pretty good yeah we used to have
we used to in the old here I haven't
seen I don't think there's any Rats up
here no in the old management's right or
wrong in the morning the only place that
we were at on 57th Street was really bad
because there was a vacant lot next to
us oh yeah and so like you'd see him I
tell you when we were doing because we
start the show now at 8:00 but when we
were starting it like 6:00 in the
morning so I would have to walk here
like oh that's prime time I literally I
remember
right in front of our building yeah he's
like fall it was like dark it was cool
and I thought that there was a whole
bunch of leaves like a lot a giant thing
of leaves blowing across the street and
I realized it was dozens of rats just
scurrying from under a car Wow
I mean and there be on 57th Street Mars
used to tell me that the garbage men
they used to it was there it was their
sport it was their game because every
day they would jump off the garbage
truck they would have a baseball bat and
one of them would pick up the garbage
bag and the other would get ready
because there's always rats under the
garbage bag right outside our bill they
don't get freaked out no no guys must be
so used to rats and Romans so they'd
have seen it all those guys have seen it
all yeah yeah I mean Owen smelled it all
that's also a very and like the chute
there's a supermarket like three blocks
up from here and every morning that I
would come in as long as it wasn't
snowing or whatever yeah like in the in
the fall and the spring especially every
morning there'd be rats scurrying across
that road in front of that super-marv
I'll tell you what's creepy is when you
see them hanging off the metal garbage
cans yeah like when you see like the
metal garbage cans that are uh they look
they almost look like a fence if you
know yeah and they crawl up there and
they're hanging off the rim and you see
sometimes six and a lot of [ __ ] thing
when there's a full it's really awful
it's awful yeah like a regular outdoor
garbage can yeah like the one was on the
left right there I think was just saw
they get we just saw there was a like
when you said you're like you 6:00 in
the morning like 6:00 in the morning
6:00 in the evening use like prime time
for the rats like that's when they'll
get up in the morning look for food or
they'll do it at the end of the day when
people are like leaving work and all the
garbage is being thrown out hey and if
you see a rat out like you see one
that's the week rat so they're the alpha
rats will send out the weaker rats to
look for food first and once they find
it and they don't die from the poison or
they aren't killed from the food they'll
come back and get all the rest of the
rats so if you see one by himself
looking around that's usually the
weakest of all oh one of the scariest
things is the organization that exists
inside the rat community so they know
what they're doing that's right there
there's there's the big alpha rat that's
just like you why don't you go check it
out yeah yeah oh yeah Wow so but if you
see a couple of them going back and
forth
VCA
than they've usually gone and gotten
everybody else and there's a scene in
the film where we found this big pile of
garbage downtown and so we're going to
the bags and they're lifting up the bags
and so you're seeing big rats middle
rats baby rats because what's happens
where they scouted the bags and then
went and got the whole colony so the
whole rat colony comes up was that just
some dude by the way who walked up about
you guys film that was a guy who works
next door I guess all you guys want to
see right look at this he just started
kicking garbage bags and I mean there
were dozens of rats in the garbage
that's [ __ ] you now you know we'll be
really awesome if you went zoom dit on
the rats and there is grossed out by
each other as we are like Tom Cruise
climbing up in the middle of those
garbage come out you're fascinating I'm
filming something this morning but great
thank you guys so much great to see you
so good Morgan thank you how do you how
do you feel about all the documentaries
that are popping up on Netflix now I
feel like okay oh I think I think
Netflix has done an awesome job of just
making making more people watched oxy
Docs I mean between Netflix and like 30
for 30 like the way that they've been in
the way they've grown the audience of
people who would never watch Docs before
is fantastic do you watch that like did
you watch the oj five-part 30 I did it I
thought it was bad that was brilliant or
something like that like [ __ ] I wish I
could do something that like epic you
know I mean it's like for 10 hours yeah
like this whole here's the whole story
well the thing is like Ezra didn't even
come in thinking it was gonna be that
big in the beginning until he started
doing his research and then sort of
saying here's what the episodes will be
and it kind of just got bigger and
bigger became this thing he's like I
think it's gonna be this long and the
Austrians like great let's do that yeah
let's do that
and they made like a TV event out of it
was incredible and it was so well done
and I think that and that's one of those
things like you know you go back five
ten years ago would not have happened in
in the States you know that's a fit
that's a very European production like
that is a very European Way of telling
story bro Graham we're going to do one
we're gonna do a six-part five-part doc
about one topic over this many nights
and the fact that we've kind of come
back to the point where now in the US we
have things like making a murderer the
jinx and the things like the oj piece
where there are these long deep dives
into like really specific topics and and
their rating through the roof and people
are eating them up and I think that
smarter fair people are seeing now that
smarter fair will win and that they can
bet on smarter fare and it'll do well
and so that's that's what I really
believe
it drives me crazy though because like I
feel like supersize me came out and that
was the first one on a mass level I know
and was populist it was a very very
popular movie and it was kind of like a
but you left going like oh maybe I
shouldn't eat that much fast food or
something or whatever yeah but like now
I can't like I can't watch any of them
anymore yes apparently there's no food
that you can eat off a it's all bad I
watched one about it
corn is bad everybody sugar cane
everything I thought I was okay but I
don't think I yeah you can't drink water
you don't know where your water's coming
from you're gonna shrivel up and die
right plus I think I've people now look
terrible because they all think they
should be skinny that's right you know
and there's no put a little weight on
it's okay but do you what do you think
of the phenomenon of nutrition docs it's
I think it's I think that again
everything in moderation big leaver
everything in moderation including
moderation I think that's uh I think you
need to you need to find the movies that
you like I think that there's topics for
everybody there's movies about veganism
and vegetarianism and animal rights and
you know your grain and and big farming
and you know agribusinesses I feel like
there's there's a lot and at some point
though you have to like say okay here's
how I'm gonna live my life yeah you know
what I think those people in Japan they
do a great job they eat a lot of fish
they don't eat any processed foods you
know they they have some rice like the
vegetables those guys they got a good
diet they have very low heart disease
that sounds all the European does those
mediterraneans over there who look so
tan and healthy and they eat all that
olive oil and right fresh food and pasta
it's like I want to do that life right
that just need to find something that
works for you and you know and just
don't be an idiot about it what if it's
like well if it's like [ __ ] I'll
figure it out in my forties you've just
described every friend I have when
you're in your 20s you're like I figured
out once I'm in my that's good kid I'm
good till 40 then you're like this fat
guy in your forties and you're like
alright then I probably this out thank
goodness I'm already married don't have
to worry about it exactly so what do you
just become like when you have a project
do you just fully invest and become I'm
gonna be obsessed with rats for for X
amount of time right however long the
shoot is and then I got and then I'm
just gonna move on to the next thing
yeah I mean I usually will balance my
time you know becoming obsessed about
one thing while we're in production on
that and that that becomes like my
number one focus but I'm usually
prepping the next thing automatically
because there's already something in the
wings and so while I'm diving into this
I mean I've already be doing some pre
research on the next thing but yeah I'd
say 90 to 95 percent of my brain powers
like invested in like vermin well we
made this the rice that was it
but then you end up being the guy at the
party who can just talk about anything
that's right the project exactly I'm
like this I'm like this amazing this
amazing encyclopedia of minimal
knowledge base understanding of
everything
yeah the base understanding of almost
everything do you live in the city I do
I live in Brooklyn how do you do it
after this [ __ ] thing that you did
that's all I'm saying so I'm in my
neighborhood it's like I was just
telling somebody this is like I've not
seen a rat in Fort Greene in a while
like never I live in a good kind of I
don't think it's right freaks I don't
think rat free is if your city's not
right for other words cigar you told me
not fanciest places you'll ever go to no
and that but I'm in a very unfasten aber
hood I just think that I don't think
there's a lot of empty lots around I
think they do a pretty good job with the
garbage so I have not seen and now now
I've just jinxed myself I have not seen
a rat in my neighborhood and probably a
year like my immediate neighbor and
that's like right like within three
blocks of my house I ever seen a rat but
if you see one it's probably just one
don't know if you see one you see if you
see one there's like there's a whole
gang of them just waiting there all over
like it's so weird to guys like I think
he's right and maybe it's because they
throw out more trash but the really
expensive neighborhoods like when you
get way way downtown like by like train
your Wall Street or go or you go up to
go up like Park Avenue or those places
where they're throwing out bags and bags
and garbage there are so many rats up
there and you'll see them like all along
Park Avenue Fifth Avenue at just certain
times when like all those giant bags of
garbage come out they figure out where
the good life is they throw out such
better settle down I should go up there
they use any of those pesky mint garbage
so what's the next what are you gonna be
working on after this this is on
Saturday at 9 p.m. on discovery correct
yeah and by the way and then so it'll be
on Saturday 9:00 p.m. on discovery
that's the premiere and then you know
with a month from now it'll be on
Netflix 35 great and 35 days it'll be on
Netflix where everybody will be able to
see it commercial free so it's gonna be
it'll be great and it's also really good
if you don't live in the city yeah it's
a great thing to watch you're like huh
so cuz I live in Westchester
right so when the thing comes up that
says Westchester New York but when it
was just the lab the science just the
science I live in an old building and
I'm like if they're in any building in
Westchester they're in my building this
movie it's one and you also want to make
sure you eat before you watch this film
so eat beforehand right before you watch
cuz you're not going to any restaurant
and you're not gonna be eating after
this ordering it i've had feeling during
the film gonna be putting whatever
you're munching on that because i worked
in a movie theater you know when i was
when i was in high school or whatever
yeah and like we would literally like it
was i I think it was like field mice
right probably but who knows sure right
and so but we or as I would say those
aren't field mice those are baby rats
I'm not treating you if I feel what you
feel I dream you fulfill mice because
like the things that we did to take care
of that place were so bad thank God the
movie theaters shut down now because
there was like where you store the candy
right yeah we would have behind the
counter not in the glass thing but the
the spare the extra candy that you would
replace the stuff with yes one shelf we
just gave up we were like okay that's
for the field mice because there's
there's droppings let me get in there
anyway and there's holes in the boxes
yeah so don't put anything on that shelf
and just like it wasn't a foot above it
that's where we'll keep the candy they
will get up there they just do the
bottom show or it was like the popcorn
like we leave it on the floor like you
we put it in a big yellow garbage bag
that's right and we just use it the next
day but why would this mice in the
theater what are you doing I can make C
do anything anything anywhere that's
right yeah we also we have this we have
this amazing film that uh this is this
is the next thing but it's not next
thing we've already finished this like
so while we were shooting rats this
other movie that we premiered at
Sundance was making the rounds and it
comes out in theaters next week so
people people this is a great thing for
people don't want to see rats you don't
like horror films we made a spectacular
family movie which
never made a g-rated movie in my life
mm-hmm and so we made this film called
the Eagle Huntress about this
thirteen-year-old girl whose father
teaches her how to hunt with like a
golden eagle yes girl is like she is
like a superhero she's it's like the
greatest girl power movie ever so
everybody like should take their kids to
see this film it is phenomenal and did
you what did you did you write direct so
so basically the director of the film
Auto Bell came to me with like 10
minutes of raw footage about two years
ago and said what do you think I said
this is amazing yeah and so we came on
and finished the whole film with him
like we basically so we brought on the
whole crew we raised all the money we
did all the reshoots who did all post I
got on I got sea to do the theme song
Daisy Ridley narrates the film and it's
awesome and so people people will love
this movie like it is it is a B we
already sold the remake rights to Fox
animation it's to just kind of figure
out the industry after after the first
one that was precise me I mean were you
just like how do I make a career out of
this I was already working in the film
TV industry just you know it was I was a
lot more hustle with a lot less success
yeah and so and so on the heels of that
is like I have a real opportunity to do
more and so we build a business and now
we do movies we do TV and we help other
filmmakers most of those I hit like like
documentary of the moment things yeah
like they don't have staying the guy
doesn't have staying power usually yeah
so you've done some time I'm much I'm
very tenacious I'm like a rat that's
right yeah I'm gonna be here I'm
sticking around I'll still be here
what's your favorite thing that you've
done do you have one or just moving to
the next nods I mean I have I have I've
listened I love all my children even the
ugly ones as my friends let me say it's
like but I had there's movies that we
that I've made that I really am proud of
like greatest movie ever sold is a movie
that I think to this day is still funny
and still still sharp in such a meta
film for those people who haven't
watched it it's a movie all about
product placement marketing and
advertising anyway I believe the film is
actually called pom wonderful presents
the greatest movie result see it work
see the branding and marketing works so
the whole idea behind it is it's a movie
all about product please mark and
advertising that was completely paid for
by product placement marketing and
advertising and it's a it is such a it's
such a mindfuck when you watch the film
like it's so great I loved I honestly
thought that one might be your favorite
too because it also
like you got to tackle something that
you have to deal with like this is like
that's actually what your as you're
making these things and making these
things to make like that's what you have
to that's right go through and now you
get to and people say people say well
maybe you could have a brand sponsor
this and I'm like no brands no response
or anything I make only my partner
Jeremy and I were like well maybe we
should try and get brands to sponsor
this there's a good idea let's try that
and it was it's just it's a great film
like I love that when I loved the film
that we made about comic-con a couple
years ago yeah that we did with Stan Lee
and Joss Whedon comic-con episode for a
fans hope like that was just such a
great fun film to make that film was
awesome because that film we made the
hole we shot the whole film in a week
because iconic because it's comic-con so
we so we shot the people who were going
to comic-con that we were following like
a couple days before and then we shot
the five days of comic-con and then we
shot them like a couple days after and
then that was it movies done there's
none there's no pickups you're gonna do
there's nothing else like movies in the
can right and so we shot all the
interviews while we were comic-con both
with like the famous folks and the fans
that were there not to mention the
people we followed so that's just that
was that was one of those where it was
so intense and so exciting and I was
sleeping like three hours a day for like
six days right but it was it was one of
the most gratifying experiences plus if
you're like you're like if I could
figure out how to do movies in three
days that's just my thing
can't I just do this and then we
actually left that and we said how can
we do more movies like this was a good
idea well I would highly recommend that
everybody sees rats it's on this
Saturday at 9 p.m. on discovery I
already have a text message from
somebody who lives here that says thank
you for ruining my muffin and day and
night [ __ ] you Morgan Spurlock
conversation so I can't imagine how
upset they're gonna be you or nothing
you are gonna love this movie it feels
like a horror movie and the sounds and
everything and you just become if you
don't leave its I stuck to my wife about
it last night and I go no it's a great
movie about how like we can't kill rats
and she goes oh you mean because we need
them and I go no because they're
stronger than us we physically can't get
rid of them I know we don't need them at
all she was what do they offer us I go I
don't think anything no no not much very
very very little they're not like
spiders are bats like they'd have a
purpose and the ego is very different
yeah they're competing with us
that's right my twin they're probably
they're the second most successful
species on the planet behind us right
for now and we'll see how the election
code that's right